[Music]
okay so to begin you're going to start
by sectioning the hair at the top and
then you're going to split it into three
smaller sections so you have a top
middle and a bottom and this will just
make ity easier to break
[Music]
down okay so the motion for cornrow in
is really you're just passing the middle
section under and then grabbing ha from
each side each time so as you can see
right now I'm about to pass my four
finger underneath the middle section
grab hair from the right hand side that
section now becomes the new middle
section section and then you take your
forefinger again pass it underneath the
middle section grab hair from the left
hand side and it's important to grab the
hair each time because that's how it
begins to uh kind of stick down to the
head to make a camea
[Applause]
basically
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
so
a
[Music]